this is a production of Cornell
University
all right if afternoon so my name is
Erin McKeown and it's great to see so
many familiar faces for the last year
and a half I'd have I've had the
pleasure of being a grad student in the
Horticulture Department and working very
closely also with cornell plantations
and their staff so I really gravitated
to public horticulture because of a love
of plants and for me public horticulture
really brings together how plants can be
used to serve ecological communities and
human communities alike and so when I
was preparing for this presentation I
was kind of asking myself why why
marketing why did you choose this topic
and what makes it exciting about public
horticulture and you guys might be
wondering that as well but for me
basically I felt that this there was a
kind of a gap in knowledge here in terms
of the collaborative aspects of public
court of public marketing and I felt
that by gaining expertise in this and
coupling that with my passion for plants
that I would be able to fill a niche
when I go and seek a career after this
master's program is over so today I'm
going to share with you some of the
results from my research while I've been
a graduate student and so just to put it
in context kind of increasingly in an
increasingly competitive marketplace
public horticulture institutions have
started joining together with other arts
and culture organizations in their area
to create what is called a public or a
collaborative marketing group which I'm
going to shorten and say CMG which I
think you guys will all enjoy hearing
better than the mouthful of
collaborative marketing group so
synonymously will use those so in this
increasingly competitive marketplace the
collaborative marketing groups have
enabled gardens and other organizations
to reduce their marketing costs and I
also tap into customer expertise and
furthermore this collaboration is a
strategy for maximizing the potential of
marketing and better addressing the
concept of destination marketing
so this project directly addressed the
knowledge gap in the field of public
horticulture related to these strategies
collaborative partnerships are socially
contrived mechanisms for collective
action a CMG is a venture shared between
a group of associated organizations that
aims to obtain greater recognition
resources and results for those
organizations when compared to those
individual organizations working alone
so CMG efforts specifically aimed to
increase the success of these
organizations as they engage in
collaborative problem-solving and they
also create a platform for information
exchange so the core research question
was our collaborative marketing groups
an effective way for Park public gardens
to market their mission to their
audience and then sequentially I also
asked what were the motivations and
conditions for that garden to join what
were some of the key activities and best
management practices being that were
outcomes of the CMG and then what were
the most valued outcomes both monetary
and non-monetary the methods that I used
to kind of obtain this data were in two
sections and the first was interviews
with five case study gardens and key
marketing staff at those gardens and the
second was an electronic survey and so
of the 30 gardens that i sent the survey
to 25 completed it so as a return rate
it was pretty good and it was such a
small sample size because each of these
gardens were participating in a
collaborative marketing group so that
was kind of like the key factor in them
getting the survey to begin with so the
survey asked about the gardens
satisfaction with their CMG performance
and it also designed to and was designed
to answer the core research questions
the interviews were the purpose of those
would were basically to understand the
current practices being employed by
these CMG's at public gardens and that
interview was conducted in two sections
so the first section was using the
business model generation canvas which I
recognized that
this you may not be able to see each of
the headers but this is a visual way of
laying out a business model and I have
basically the experience of using this
is you bring a big like 6 x 5 version of
this into a room where you have
shareholders stakeholders in the
conversation and then we use post-it
notes and kind of dialogue to then
populate each area so it's a way of
visually representing the business model
and outlining you know what is the what
is the value proposition of the mission
of the garden who are their customers
their audience and then what are the
channels that they reach reach that
audience with so so on and so forth and
then when we got to the section of key
partners we turn to the conversation to
ask how did the CMG basically open up
new channels or provide key activities
or key resources for them to achieve
their mission which in non-profit
horticulture is paramount achieving the
mission so this is just kind of here for
a visual aid but if anybody's interested
in learning more about the canvas and
the business model generation handbook I
talk to you about that later and could
provide more resources so I'm going to
go through each of the five case study
interviews now and basically the second
part of the interview which I failed to
comment on was a series of open-ended
questions and so the summary of each
interview i'm about to provide is the
canvas and that that the open-ended
questions so really was obviously
qualitative analysis and we had a lot of
fun while we were doing it and it was
reciprocal the gardens gained a lot out
of that process of going through the
canvas and then i gained quite a bit of
information as well so my first
interview was with cornell plantations
right here in ithaca and they are part
of a collaborative effort of local
cultural institutions called the
Discovery Trail which many of you
hopefully are aware of discovery trail
partnership is a group of nonprofit
organizations based here that promote
the awareness and understanding of
connection of the connections between
art history literature science and the
natural world the goal of the Discovery
Trail is to collectively market the
member organizations to tourists that
are over 90 miles
away and so this is a region which
Cornell plenty that that tourist
audience is a region that's a little bit
less attainable for gardens specifically
Cornell plantations to put not valuable
marketing resources to so Discovery
Trail really aids in in compensating for
that in a way so Discovery Trail is
supported by annual membership dues as
well as through the strategic tourism
the Tompkins County strategic tourism
board and again I'm I'll mention its
main function is to increase public
awareness and positively impact the
visitation of each of the member member
organizations to discovery trail so one
of the things that is evolved out of
this successful partnership over time is
an educational program called kids the
kids discover the trail and so this was
kind of a learning moment in you know
even just the first interview where I
realized that the longevity or the age
of a collaborative marketing group
influenced the level of their activities
so for example discovery trail once they
became more seasoned decided to create
and evolve or basically formalize this
educational program through there
through their shared kind of
collaboration and I'll come back to that
point later in the outcomes so other non
monetary but benefits of the discovery
trail for plantations include
strengthening their branded cultural
identity of Ithaca so really creating
more of a destination marketing brand
here in Ithaca for for people that
aren't living here to when they come
visit they can really identify with what
there is to do when you visit and then
top of mind awareness in potential
customer audiences mind so that goes for
both regional people that live here and
then people that are visiting creating
that top of mind awareness my second
interview is with garden in the woods
which is headquartered which is the
headquarters for a New England wild
flower society and the Massachusetts
garden botanic garden group was
established in 2012 to better leverage
the various public gardens throughout
the state of Massachusetts and so this
was created by the recommendation of the
Massachusetts office of travel and
tourism so there was actually an outside
you know body saying you all yu gardens
need to get together and create this and
they also felt that strength in numbers
would really enable them to increase
audience awareness of the 11
participating gardens and make kind of a
viable and robust partnership if they if
they joined together so the CMG is still
in the early stages of its development
but it's already impacted how New
England wildflower society thinks about
marketing it funded through member dues
and as well as they are able to gain
financial support from convention and
visitors bureaus and the Massachusetts
office of travel and tourism so that's
that's funding that they wouldn't have
access to if they weren't collaborating
another another kind of key outcome so
this this CMG provides a really key
marketing channel and the vehicle for
that is a shared website and that's a
that's been a common theme so these
CMG's create websites to collectively
tell what's going on so whether that's
through an events calendar or just
simply through creating links to their
websites this is a way to achieve a more
dynamic marketing mix for gardens that a
lot of times don't have a very very
substantial marketing budget so
furthermore this CMG strengthens New
England wildflower society's
relationship with their peer gardens and
it really does in for reinforced that
climate for knowledge sharing among
professionals so much in non-profit
horticulture are you know any nonprofit
field there are various people working
in the same positions trying to achieve
the same goals and so if we can share
kind of dated it you know knowledge
about day-to-day activities about how to
best achieve you know the promotion of
these individual organizations that
basically is what the CMG is able to
formalize the process of so Chicago
Botanic Garden was my third interview
and destination marketing is kind of an
ever important strategy for nonprofit
gardens to use so
increasing in order to increase their
visitation and attendance due north is
the collaborative that Chicago is a part
of and these organizations have joined
forces to kind of like bring attention
to the do the North Shore region which
is 40 minutes north of downtown Chicago
and so the reason why this is
significant is because you know people
go to Chicago to go to downtown but they
don't necessarily know what's going on
in that in that neighborhood up there
and so there is a wealth of cultural
organizations there and they've decided
to join together to cross program and
cross market so the interview with
Chicago Botanic Garden revealed that due
north has not just an economic impact on
the garden but also on the region as a
whole by attracting tourists to that
area so in addition to this destination
marketing strategy the collaborative
also impacts their bottom line by
appealing to a few key donors and this
was also kind of a big realization from
this interview and the one that I'll
talk about next so people that give
large large contributions to gardens
then want to have some involvement in in
the decision making and kind of the
future of how that garden is going to be
portrayed to its audience and so the
staff at the Chicago Botanic Garden
really felt that they were serving this
key these key donors wishes by
demonstrating that they're using their
philanthropic contributions in an
effective way by collaborating with
these other organizations and basically
creating a brand to promote the whole
area not just their garden so the public
response also has been very positive to
the due north collaborative because they
like seeing the organizations in their
area work collaboratively so that brings
me to red butte garden in Salt Lake City
which is part of a CMG called Foothill
cultural district which is comprised of
seven destinations along salt lake
city's full of Foothill Boulevard the
mission of this marketing group is to
provide visitors with the opportunity to
experience Utah's fascinating art
culture history
in stunning natural areas in an easily
accessible way and using public
transportation so the foothills cultural
district also was really created because
of the vision of a local philanthropist
Zeke Dumke who also gave significant
contributions to the garden and has like
you know like a building named after him
and things like this so he's like one of
our key donors and really important and
he said to them and the other
organizations he said hey I give to all
of you individually I really want you
all to work together and so they you
know they threw they did some trialing
and some piloting of those that program
and then it basically was formalized in
2004 and some of their some of the key
key resources that comes out of this
collaborative marketing group is they
really can leverage the collaboration
when they're applying for grants so they
end up acquiring funds because they
state that they're in collaboration with
these other organizations and they're
also part of a cultural tax district
that you know looks favorably upon their
call their collaborative efforts so this
culture of collaboration also creates
the perception that red butte and the
other member gardens are community
players and so again this is kind of
evolved in the direction of more shared
programming and it's not just it's no
longer just a marketing platform it's my
final interview was at the Scott
Arboretum in media Pennsylvania and
anybody has been to the philly area you
know that that area is rich in botanical
gardens and our berita and the Scott
Arboretum is unique they're part of two
separate collaborative marketing groups
and the first one I'm going to comment
on is called greater philadelphia
gardens and that is the oldest
collaborative that i interviewed and
it's comprised of 30 member gardens in a
30-mile radius of philadelphia so that's
a high density of gardens and that
regional proximity was kind of the basis
for why they created the collaborative
back in the 80s but it also then evolved
because you know it creates this
knowledge sharing among gardens as
as I've mentioned before so some of the
key activities of Greater Philadelphia
Gardens is that they work to promote the
member gardens across the board so some
of the members in that cmgr like really
well-known gardens for example Longwood
which probably many of you have heard of
but then there's others which are lesser
known and so the benefit that each of
these members are afforded is that their
reputation is extended by way of being
associated with these other bigger
Gardens so another really key activity
is that that the pooling of those
resources enables greater philadelphia
gardens to market to an international
audience and so what i want to give just
as a moment to recognize is that like
that i didn't interview them but the
bartram's garden is really small but has
huge historic significance and their
visitation levels are like low and just
like every like many nonprofit gardens
you know has struggled financially but
what they've tracked through google
analytics and through their attendance
is that because of greater philadelphia
gardens marketing to an international
audience they get tons of international
visitors and it's they couldn't pay to
market the way that greater philadelphia
gardens is marketing for them that makes
sense so that was just a really key key
learning for my interview with them so
the second partnership that i'd like to
just talk about briefly with the Scott
Arboretum is one that's more web-based
it's called the Delaware County Arts
consortium and they are focused on a web
platform and calendar events calendar
called greater the Philly fun guide and
basically it's it's a way for the Scott
Arboretum to market to people regionally
because even though you're seated in a
community and you think have you have a
good handle on how to best access people
in your community there's always there's
always new ways to reach them and so
this website really enables Scott the
Scott Arboretum to reach a local
audience that they previously didn't
know how to sew the conditions for
joining
we're kind of really a big key focus for
this study and by definition
collaboration requires that a certain
amount of autonomy is kind of as
saccharose is sacrificed by the garden
so they have to work together in order
to and put their their own objectives
kind of on the side so what's really key
before starting to create a
collaborative we're deciding if you want
to join one would be that you know you
want to understand the institutional
factors of the other organizations that
you're joining it you want to understand
the culture and the organizational goals
and then secondarily a major theme was
that nonprofit leaders whether they be
executive directors or key donors were a
huge influential motivation for why a
garden would join existing network and
regional proximity also greatly
influenced the likelihood of a
collaborative either being created or
someone deciding to join so just to
share some of the results of the
electronic survey the motivation to
collaborate must be based on the CMG's
ability to kind of attain outcomes that
the garden couldn't achieve on its own
so the survey respondents basically
stated that this was a strategic
decision for them and that joining the
collaboration was really like paramount
was that they wanted to join together
with the other arts and cultural
organizations to create that strength in
numbers concept and then moving into
audience which we've talked about before
but really accessing a wider tourist
audience through shared marketing
activities was another major priority
for these gardens CMG has helped to
establish kind of transactional
relationships with visitors but this the
research was not showing that anything
beyond a transactional relationship was
created so what I mean by that is people
found out about the garden or the
organizations in the area and they went
and visited but they didn't necessarily
buy a membership or become donors and so
that's a way that when you deepen the
programmatic involvement by creating
something like kids discover the trail
you can start to draw in
more of a relational relationship with
that audience so some of the key
activities were shared visibility and
the vehicle for that was oftentimes a
website than just creating an economy of
scale for these gardens to promote their
garden through a website and lessen the
individual marketing costs that was a
major driving force and furthermore the
interviews backed up that the CMG opened
up new channels so they were actually
able to access new customers or audience
that wasn't previously kind of available
to them through the collaborative and
lastly from the electronic survey the
respondents answered that the most
valuable outcomes was increased
publicity and visibility of their garden
gardens indicated that the CMG had
improved relations with regional
cultural institutions because it
facilitated and formalized partnerships
and collaborations that were already
happening and so they were now given you
know they were given permission in a way
to and given you know a platform to
stand on in order to collaborate with
one another so across all interviews the
larger the garden and the more
established the collaborative marketing
group the more concrete the contributors
or my interviewees were on why their
garden was involved and so I guess that
kind of goes without saying but it was
still interesting to kind of look at
collaborative that were anywhere from
develops starting founded in 1980s all
the way up to 2012 and so each
interviewee really highly valued the
triple bottom line theory which really
takes into account and adds value to
social capital reputation awareness
building as viable outcomes of the
collaborative so more more performance
evaluation is needed you can't just say
yes we're you know we're having we have
these non-monetary outcomes and they're
really good I mean it's good to have a
solid understanding of that but more
benchmarking would definitely benefit
leaders in terms of decision-making and
validating their their involvement in
this
and so in conclusion collaborative
marketing groups proved to be a really
effective way for organizations to work
in concert to achieve larger scale
advertising while saving money and
resources they provide a solution to
align media and publicity expenditures
and help to stretch individual budgets
while diversifying the marketing mix of
individual individual organizations
having a better understanding of the
benefits of a CMG would enable public
garden leaders to comprehend the value
of collaboration and justify the
resources and staff time that they
allocate to it furthermore improved
forecasting would definitely help to
help them to make informed decisions so
ideally the findings from this study
will and the use of the BMG canvas and
future research will help to provide
knowledge that is required to
successfully engage in these formal
collaborations so I just want to thank
the professor's my advisors and
committee members the fellow public
garden leadership students and all of
you for listening today thank you very
much
you
question well that's where social
reputation really comes into play and as
you know when the when community members
or members of these these organizations
view that large garden as being
philanthropic themselves in sharing
their brand and sharing their reputation
that's kind of where they gain the
benefit and so yeah it's really in the
nonprofit field you can kind of create
things based on non-monetary I don't
really know how to answer this question
but basically they gain an improved
reputation from it and this can this
this happens more often in a non-profit
scenario that helped to answer any other
questions thank you
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu